ah
all right to celebrate birthday this
friday we're helping you green your life
all this week it here with a recipe that
is both delicious and good for the
environment please welcome Abby sharp is
very good for you cheers office so we're
going to talk about throw things out
like we did to begin the show what does
metabolism mean I want to talk about
what does sustainable food meat so what
is the definition what was so if I
sustainable seafood just means that you
caught or farmed in ways that are not
gonna harm the environment yeah and
unfortunately there's no hard and fast
rules when it comes to sustainability
it's kind of complicated stuff so it's
not like you can just see an organic
label and no that's sustainable right so
you really do have to ask a lot of
questions of your fishmonger before you
buy so you go to the fish counter yeah
and then you ask the following question
what is the name of the fish yes that is
important and that's important and in
that because you want to know they're
like sort of the history of the vision
where it's far right so you want the
specific so for example you probably
know it's tuna if you're buying to not
yeah but you want to know is it albacore
is a big I is a bluefin those details
are really important because some
specific species may be a greater risk
of becoming endangered okay but as a
general rule of thumb usually the
smaller fish tend to be more sustainable
simply because they're they got their
more abundant in the ocean right right
and also they might be healthier too
because they've lived shorter lives so
they've accumulated fewer toxins like
mercury it does matter where it's caught
absolutely yeah so where it caught where
it's caught is very important and again
more detail the better so sometimes
knowing Pacific versus Atlantic versus
Mediterranean is enough but if you can
get those real good details like the
Gulf of st. Lawrence for example that
would be an ideal amount of information
to get well how come I hug up that's
what because it really does do it really
does determine the the sustainability at
the object ok and then how it's caught
is it hot deals caught yeah your type is
important things like bottom trawls
drift Nets long lines these are gear
that tend to sweep up the bottom of the
ocean and kills off everything in its
path yeah yeah yeah so whenever possible
I like to look for a fish that we caught
with hooker line and or trap caught
which is a lot more specific and
sustainable so we're going to take a
look at a couple things here how do we
know if we're making the right choice
and this is what you're another lesson
from Abby so we'll take a look at
there's a
there's an app yeah so obviously this is
so complicated that you don't need to
figure it out yourself okay once you've
got this information there's a lot of
Technology so one of my favorite apps is
by sea choice and you just plug in all
that great information that you got from
your seen your fishmonger and it'll tell
you whether or not it's a sustainable
choice so you can see why that level of
detail is important because it really
does depend on the specific species
where it came from how was caught and
like for example sometimes wild-caught
may be sustainable but in other cases
it's not like it's not so yeah you need
that level of detail I emotion wise app
as well absolutely same idea they might
kick all right you can see there's our
arctic char so that was kind of the
inspiration for our recipe today okay I
love this okay so you're making maple
glazed arctic char braised cabbage and
Apple oh that's delicious beautiful I'll
be a little bit about arctic char cuz I
let's take oh good it's so flavorful
between like a salmon trout but this
arctic char is farmed in a closed
land-based farming system which is a
really sustainable way of okay fishing
and I love it because it's actually a
fish that's high in omega-3s but low in
those in that mercury so it's kind of my
all-around great piece great fish so
we're just going to get these guys a
little bit of salt into salt and pepper
and it truly is one of my favorite fish
oh it's so so beautiful and then what
pills fancier than going for salmon
regular ginger are char um so it goes
into the oven for 450 degrees and we'll
just pop that in there I've got them
ready to go but in the meantime let's
work a little bit I know magic
television let's work on our I'll bring
us over here our cabbage okay so really
really super simple this is a side dish
I make in my home like every day ok so
again with the arctic char cuz you don't
want to overcook the fish ok so you put
it in the middle rack top rap Oh
probably the middle rack okay especially
if you have a nice convection oven you
want to get that nice one here and how
long it again it usually will take about
10 to 12 minutes from impending on the
thickness and then again the temperature
is 450 we're gonna do I get it get it
done quick right so now cabbage how
about that yeah yeah so let's just turn
this down just a touch so touch a little
bit of oil in the bottom of the pan
there hey just gonna get this cabbage
down
and I like the purple cabbage because
it's colorful and it looks nice but
control to use whatever you have have it
just such an expensive vegetable talked
about that too long ago was a long way
doesn't it oh so a little bit of Apple
as well because I liked a bit of
sweetness with it and some water just to
get the steam kind of steam going ok and
then whoo you always get a party don't
you are gonna stick up this i know i
know i'm sorry i looked at their rent
out tonight said she's making fish and
cabbage I know it's gonna be a snob
Talia bnn is not gonna be happy you're
just down the hallway but it's ok fine
yeah ok so we got some low-sodium soy
sauce this is just going to give a
little bit salty kick and some maple
syrup so I like the sweet salty combo
going on oh I like it and then I think
it smells really good already and then
we're gonna put the lid on just let this
team it takes pretty much as long as the
fish so everything's gonna happen at the
same time and then we make a really
quick glaze which just basically has a
lot of the same kind of an attorney
about this this is interesting yeah so
we've got some maple syrup some of that
low sodium soy sauce right I graded some
ginger fresh zippy delicious ginger and
a bit bit of cornstarch just to thicken
it up and the reason I don't put this
right on the fish when I cook it is that
it would burn and then I've had to clean
up a baking sheet with all that sugar
Burton and those guys got time for that
now we've got time yeah yeah so
basically all we're gonna do is take a
little brush brush brush brush on our
beautiful pieces of Arctic chimes yeah
do it after the fact of course so that
you don't get that you don't have all
that sticking and then our cabbage is
all ready to go Oh long is that and i
just finished off with a little bit of
almonds and some of those green onions
and it's a perfect low carb high protein
dinner okay now I've got a question for
ya the fish counter yep how do you know
how much fish to get what are your
family like it sure cuz I know that my
cameraman would eat the whole thing
right it happens um so generally i would
say anywhere usually in that 4 ounce
portion is enough for a good person ok
so yeah you're looking for a family of
four now you're looking at about 16
ounce and how long would you buy the
fish right how long at use during the
refrigerator ready
how long is it good until like a day I
usually I don't credit it as quickly as
possible paper you want it to be fresh
you want you know you want that quality
exactly a be sharp thanking you can find
this delicious recipe on Maryland on CA
we're gonna say goodbye thanks for
watching everybody have a great day
Oh